listen everyone has their own truth of
how they think something happened the
Kardashians season 3 teaser is here and
Kim's unleashing her feelings on a
mystery sister you think I need your
permission I wish I could tell you this
is gonna be a mild relaxing Serene
season
it's not totally fine the famous TV
fam's Hulu reality series returns May
25th and as Scott Disick promises I've
never seen this much drama in my life
one of the biggest moments being
platinum blonde Kim yelling at someone
and she is angry you think I need your
permission yeah the shop pants to her
younger sisters Kylie and Kendall Jenner
but as far as who's actually on the
receiving end of Kim's wrath is TBD you
just gotta roll with it as for what's
causing Kim's rage well fans think her
split from Pete Davidson could be the
reason
like so cute
yeah yeah we saw some cute moments like
that on the show do you want to shower
with me really quick
what just happened but ahead of the
season 2 premiere the two called it
quits after nine months of dating people
don't see the context behind it but
Kim's not the only one dealing with a
breakup Kenny's also going through
something personal it all comes back to
protecting my piece after season two
ended the model and NBA star Devin
Booker called it quits after two years
of dating what's happening with you and
Devin Booker
um he's my boyfriend
and since then she's been spotted out
with Bad Bunny the source told E.T
earlier this month they really like each
other but they're taking things slow oh
my God just be cool it's fine as far as
seeing the Puerto Rican rapper on the
show don't count on it just from a
really young age I think both Kylie and
I kind of knew what we wanted to keep
off the show or what we wanted to keep
to ourselves and um yeah I think that
it's kind of as simple as that so what's
in store for Courtney well she and her
now hubby Travis Barker got married in
Italy following the season 2 finale I
have a super busy week ahead tomorrow's
fitting is the most important one which
is my actual wedding dress and his
actual wedding outfit
we saw the lead up and now fans May
finally see the dreamy ideas in season
three it's a beautiful thing but it
seems like something else is brewing
between court and her family there's no
sense of loyalty I think that you have a
real insight into what the girls are
doing not only you know what you see in
the press or whatever but what's really
happening behind the scenes as for Chloe
since season two aired she and her ex
Tristan Thompson have continued to
co-parent their two kiddos true and
their eight-month-old son whose name
they have yet to reveal I wish I could
tell you this is going to be a mild
relaxing Serene season
it's not
Kylie's also raising two kids with her
on and off bow Travis Scott seems this
season she's got babies and branding on
the brain we have huge influence what
are we doing with our power
so
let's talk about it
we'll just have to wait for season three
to drop May 25th on Hulu to see what
cameras captures just tune in because
you never know what's gonna happen
foreign